*Disneycember theme*
I've been introduced to a lot of interesting kid's shows over the years
Adventure Time, Gravity Falls, Steven Universe
But somehow, Phineas and Ferb has missed my eye.
I do see people dress up like them at cons,
and even some kids wearing T-shirts and stuff but-
I really don't
have any Idea of what the show's about.
Just that people think it's good and getting a bit of a following.
Well, after seeing 'Phineas and Ferb across the 2nd Dimension'
I can definitely see why.
This is definitely a strange but highly entertaining idea.
The plot of the show, if read the movie correctly is that
two boys named Phineas and Ferb go on wild anventures
with their pet Perry, a platypus.
And yet somehow have no idea that they're going on these wild adventures.
because Perry keeps his secret identity of a secret agent a secret.
Their sister Candace always try to get them in trouble but the mother never sees what they're up to.
Well this time things are a little different
As Dr. Doof, Perry's arch nemesis creates a device
that can go into parallel dimensions where he actually is incredibly powerful and has taken over the world.
Of course when that successful Dr. Doof finds out about the device.
He wants to use it to take over even more dimensions.
Starting with the one Phineas and Ferb are from.
But in order to save them Perry has to revel his secret identity.
This creates a riff in there friendship and they don't know if they can ever trust one another again.
And things get even crazier when they meet themselves in the parallel dimensions
Find their usually the opposite.
And try to utilize their strengthens and weaknesses
to work together and stop the evil takeover.
The best way I can describe this movie is think:
Kim Possible meets Rick and Morty for kids.
But still a funny Rick and Morty.
The humor is very fast, very strange, and very visual.
Even though not every joke gets a hard laugh
they keep throwing them at you so quickly that you forget the ones you didn't laugh at
are just having so much fun with the ones you are.
Even though I've never seen an episode of the show. I can quickly figure out what the running jokes are.
Perry never talks, Ferb usually doesn't talks,
Phineas is optimistically naive,
and the parents never figure out what going on.
With the sister getting more and more angry.
With that said I do feel theres a couple of things I would probably enjoy more if I watched the show.
For example in the last third all these other animal critters show up
and I don't really know who they are but I'm sure they were in  the shows.
Theres also all these strange robots and inventions that come out of no where
and they look so well design
they must have been from the series.
I'm assuming everyone of these creations probably had there own episode and there
all coming together here.
Which for a fan would be a really really big deal.
Heck Perry reviling his true identity is a big deal.
But for someone who hasn't seen the show it's still pretty entertaining.
There nice if not simple characters
living in a very bizarre and surreal world.
At first I was kind of thrown off by the animation
I don't know something about the designs are really weird.
Are they suppose to be shaped like the first letters of their names.
But in the last third the action scenes are amazing.
Look at how quick they are look at how smooth it is.
Its just one crazy energized thing after another crazy energized thing.
And it never lets up it just keeps going and going and going and its a ton of fun.
So yeah i feel like I would like this movie a lot more if I did watched the show.
But at the same time it does encourage me to go and watch the show.
It's seem really cute, creative, and funny all at the same time.
Definitely something I wouldn't mind checking out.
So whether you're a fan the show or a complete new comer,
slap on you fedora for secret agent craziness.
*outro music*